après des mois d'attentes le québec est
enfin prête à passer à la vitesse
supérieure c'est une excellente nouvelle
qui ont commencé la vaccination massive
parce que justement les vaccins qu'on a
notre disposition sont extrêmement
efficaces durant les essais cliniques
les deux produits ont démontré une
grande efficacité contre les symptômes
sévères de la maladie
même avec une seule dose la protection
est élevé selon des données récentes ne
s'est pas dans les études randomisées
contrôlées avec du vrai monde avec plein
de conditions médicales sous jacente des
personnes plus âgées mères et avec tous
et tous ces bémols on a quand même une
efficacité après une première dose à +
80% des vaccins nous protège également
du variable britannique et possiblement
de celui de fric du sud ça ça nous donne
une bouffée d'air frais parce que ça
veut dire que étant donné que les
variants ne sont pas encore dominants
dans notre société
ça nous donne le temps de bien se
vacciner quant aux effets secondaires
sérieux ils sont rares un cas par 10
mille personnes vaccinées un événement
qu'il faut quand même discuté c'est
qu'il donne pas mal de réactions au
moment de la vaccination surtout au
niveau local parfois fatigue mal de tête
fièvre et plus jeunes beaucoup plus que
chez les plus vieux
déçus ils ne sont pas parfaits en
outaouais 23 résidents avec ce n'est de
ch et celle des ont été contaminées ces
derniers jours
la bonne nouvelle la plupart sont
asymptomatiques
les autres ont des symptômes légers et
puis on ignore encore combien teint ces
vaccins vous nous protéger dit mois ou
des années on n'a pas vraiment le choix
que de serre vacciner à temps de voir
venir parce que on n'avait pas le luxe
de demander aux compagnies de faire leur
suivi pendant deux ans pour prendre
combien de temps les gens étaient
protégés mais le principal handicap du
vaccin actuel c'est peut-être licitation
de 30 % des québécois à se vacciner mène
au travers de la santé ont des doutes
plus de doute en fait que leurs
collègues américains peuvent accéder et
justes efficaces si rome dans le bras
d'une personne parce qu'un vaccin
efficace à 90% sur une tablette le ca
enraye pas une épidémie ici normand
grondin radio canada
m